تشير التوقعات الى ان العطله الصيفيه هذا
العام ستؤذي جيوب المسافرين فيما تشكل
انفراجات لشركات الطيران بعد الخسائر
الناتجه عن اغلاقات كورونا فيما تبقى
المطارات عالقه بين الزياد عدد المسافرين
وعدم القدره الماليه على مواكبه الطلب
الكبير وبحسب تصريح للرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
راين اير لصحيفه التليجراف مايكل اوليري
فان متوسط اسعار التذاكر في جميع انحاء
اوروبا ارتفع 20% العام الماضي ويتوقع هذا
الصيف ان تقفز الاسعار مره اخرى بالقدر
نفسه تقريبا ووفقا لمدير السفر في امريكا
فان الرحله من نيويورك الى هونغ كونغ في
الدرجه الاقتصاديه تكلف اليوم ضعف ما كانت
عليه في عام 2019 وما يقرب من الثلث اكثر
من العام الماضي والسبب هو ان شركات
الطيران لديها عدد اقل من المقاعد المتاحه
حاليا مقارنه بمست قبل الجائحه بسبب اتجاه
اطلق عليه اسم السفر الانتقامي حيث يخطط
الناس لرحلات اطول في صيف 20 23 هذا
بالتاكيد ترجم الى عوائد جاءت ضعف
التوقعات فقد سجلت شركه اي اي جي المالكه
للخطوط الجويه البريطانيه ارباحا فصليه
افضل من المتوقع ورفع توقعاتها للعام
باكمله واعلنت طيران الامارات والخطوط
الجويه سنغافوريه عن تحقيق ارباح قياسيه
ايضا وبحسب لا يتضاعفت شركات الطيران
العالميه توقعات ارباحها لعام 2023 الى
9.8 مليار دولار من 4.7 مليار دولار اذا
تبدو الصوره ايجابيه لشركات الطيران ولكن
بحسب مجلس المطارات الدولي لمنطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ فان الزياده الحاده في
اسعار تذاكر الطيران تعيق تعافي النظام
البيئي للطيران
وخصوصا المطارات فقد خسر العديد من
المساهمين في المطارات اموالهم لمده عشره
فصول متتاليه اذ لا تزال المطارات تفتقر
الى المرونه لرفع اسعار الرسوم والتعريفات
وحذر مطار لندن هيثرو من الخسائر المستمره
وامتنع عن دفع الارباح للمساهمين
وكانت قد اشتدت الخلافات المتكرره حول
رسوم الهبوط بالمطار في اعقاب كورونا
افتلقت شركات الطيران المزيد من الدعم
المالي المباشر ولديه الان الحريه في رفع
الاسعار بالسرعه في الوقت الذي تواصل فيه
المطارات ضخ الموارد في منشاتها من توسعات
وتمديد المدارج والاتمه وتركيب اجهزه مسح
متطوره دون الحصول على استثمارات اضافيه
قال سامي نائب الرئيس في اي سي اف المختصه
بابحاث السفر والضيافه بالنسبه للمطارات
ياتي 60% من ايراداتها من رسوم اله بوط
بينما بالنسبه لشركات الطيران تمثل رسوم
المطر جزءا صغيرا من اجمالي تكاليفها عاده
في حدود خمسه الى سته في المئه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات